we're going to begin though in
Pennsylvania with a senate race it's got
huge implications for the country and
which party has power in Washington now
this was a first and only debate between
Democrat John fetterman and Republican
memade included fiery exchanges on
abortion rights the economy and a range
of other issues but with early voting
already underway John fetterman's Health
was also a topic Robert Costa is
following this campaign Bob good morning
to you he started right off the bat
saying let's address the elephant in the
room good to see you
did he did Gail good morning good to be
with you last night's debate it was a
crucial Crossroads in the battle for the
Senate it was also reflective of the
state of politics in Pennsylvania and
the nation tense exchanges on the issues
and on character
and let's also talk about the elephant
in the room I had a stroke he's never
let me forget that Lieutenant Governor
John Federman started off the hour-long
debate assuring voters he's still
capable of doing the job of Senator five
months after having a stroke I might
miss some words during this debate mush
two words together but it knocked me
down but I'm going to keep coming back
up while his GOP opponent Dr mehmedaz
went straight to attacking his opponent
as soft on crime John Federman during
this crime wave has been trying to get
as many murderers convicted and
sentenced to life in prison out of jail
as possible he has no experience he has
never made any attempt to try to address
crime during his entire career except
showing up for photo ops here in
Philadelphia the two clashed on abortion
I don't want the federal government
involved with that at all I want women
doctors local political leaders letting
the Democracy that's always allowed our
nation to thrive to put the best ideas
forward so states can decide died for
themselves if you believe that the
choice for abortion belongs between you
and your doctor that's what I fight for
Roe v Wade for me is should be the law
he celebrated when Roe v Wade went down
the abortion decision should be left up
the states and specifically when John
Farrell
and things got heeded when they were
asked about families struggling with the
high cost of college tuition basically
what John fetterman and Joe Biden are
are arguing for is for plumbers who
didn't go to college and couldn't for a
bunch of reasons afford it to pay the
bills of lawyers who went to graduate
school and haven't paid their debt back
Dr Oz you know loves free free money
when it's a half a million dollar tax
break on one of his you know homes down
in a ranch in Florida and whether it was
a 50 tax break you know about his farm
in Montgomery County so veterans use of
a closed captioning device during the
debate where he read questions in real
time on his screen above the moderators
spark debate on social media with some
Observer seen a strong performance amid
recovery While others cast him as
unsteady I I do support fracking and
I don't I don't
I support fracking and I stand and I do
support fracking betterment would not
say if he would release more of his
medical records but argued that he has
been transparent I believe if my doctor
believes that I'm fit to serve and and
that's what I believe is appropriate
fetterman's advisors tell CBS news that
in the coming days they will make
abortion rights a focal point and they
claim that in the hours after the debate
fetterman raised more than one million
dollars meanwhile mem and Oz will
campaign today with Nikki Haley the
former Trump Administration Diplomat
Gail
Bob you know the race for governor big
story in the news in Pennsylvania where
do things stand with that one
our CBS News Battleground tracker poll
shows the Democratic nominee attorney
general Josh Shapiro ahead of state
senator Doug mastriano a trump Ally I
sat down with Shapiro here in Harrisburg
Pennsylvania and he says he's ahead
because he's reaching out to Republicans
in the suburbs of Philadelphia and
Pittsburgh who don't want to side with a
trump Ally and an election denier
all right Bob we thank you we'll see you
later on